this is jocko podcast number 286
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening and also
joining us again
dave burke
good evening dave
good evening so
if you haven't listened to
285 just go back and listen to 285 right
now we are exploring some of the works
of bh liddell hart
i explain who he is on 285 he's a
british soldier world war one
military theorist military historian
wrote influenced he's a he's an
influencer
he's kind of an og influencer really a
pioneer and he legit was he had a lot of
influence inside the british military he
had
influence in all kinds of different
military organizations
including some enemy military
organizations that actually listened to
what he had to say
so if you haven't listened to 285 yet go
back listen to 285 and we're going to
jump right back in
to his book which is called strategy
it's a
we the last one we covered was the
strategy of the indirect approach this
look everything he does is tied into the
strategy of indirect approach
and and we're going to jump back into
this his other book well he's got many
books
one of his other books called
simply strategy bh liddell heart here we
go
dave anything before i just jump right
into this thing no let's do it okay so
we're going to get into a section here
called
basis of strategy and i think it's very
interesting how this one kicks off
a deeper truth to which fock and other
disciples of klaus fritz did not
penetrate fully is that in war every
problem and every principle
is a duality
like a coin it has two faces so this may
remind you of another book you might
have heard of called the dichotomy of
leadership there you go again i think i
owe this guy some royalties
i did no i mean
i could have called the book the duality
of leadership but i didn't
right we called the dichotomy of
leadership like a coin it has two faces
hence the need for well a
well-calculated compromise as a means to
reconciliation what does that mean be
balanced
big shocker
this is the inevitable consequence of
the fact that war is a two-party affair
so imposing the need that while hitting
one must guard
this just that you got to balance the
dichotomies of leadership you can't just
be on a total offense you got to have
your guard up you can't just have your
guard up you got to go on offense you
got to be balanced it's a corollary that
in order to hit with effect the enemy
must be taken off his guard effective
concentration can only be obtained when
the opposing forces are dispersed and
usually in order to ensure this one's
own forces must be widely distributed
thus by an outward paradox true
concentration is the product of
dispersion
so isn't this interesting we have to
concentrate our forces but we have to
disperse our forces in order to
dis dislocate and put the enemy off
balance so there's a dichotomy
we have to be
together so we can
act effectively but we have to be spread
out so we can put the enemy off balance
what happens if we get too far spread
out well now we're now we're weak what
happens if we're too concentrated well
now we can't disperse the we can't
dislocate the enemy
a further consequence of the two-party
condition
is that to ensure reaching an objective
one should have
an alternative objective or alternative
objectives plural
herein lies a vital contrast to the
single minded 19th century doctrine of
fock and his fellows a contrast of the
practical to the theoretical for if the
enemy is certain as to your point of aim
he has the best possible chance of
guarding himself and blunting your
weapon
this is why in jiu-jitsu you have to do
more than one move you can't just grab
the arm and think you're gonna get the
arm lock it's not gonna work
if on the other hand you take a line
that threatens alternative objectives
you distract his mind and his forces
this moreover is the most economic
method of distraction for it allows you
to keep the largest proportion of your
force available on your real line of
operation thus reconciling the greatest
possible concentration with the nes the
necessity of dispersion
so
you have to have some different
objectives if you just grab the arm
that's not gonna if you just flank if
you're like okay hey we're gonna flank
the enemy okay the enemy goes oh wait
looks like they're moving over there
cool now we adjust our forces and now
that flank becomes the front
so you have to have multiple objectives
now what if you go to flank and they
think oh that's not just a that's just a
fake move so now they don't put their
forces world then you attack it but if
you only have one objective
and the enemy recognizes what that is
they're going to defend it heavily and
you're not going to be able to achieve
victory
the absence of an alternative
is contrary to the very nature of war
it sins against the light which borset
shed in the 18th century by his most
penetrating dictum
that quote every plan
of campaign ought to have several
branches
and to have been so well thought out
that one or the other of the said
branches cannot fail of success
so you got to have multiple
branches
and they should be well enough thought
out that one of them is going to work
one of one of those branches one of
those lines of operation is going to
work
this was the light that his military
heir the young napoleon bonaparte
followed in
seeking always as he said you guys want
me to go french
uh yeah kind of uh
fair son fame endure
fascions
there you go yeah
what does that mean
it means make your theme in two ways
you you've got to have two different
approaches
and it's just he calls it it's a sin
against the the old dictums right which
was a god you gotta have a focus you
gotta aim for that concentrate your
forces in one spot it's like cool what
if the enemy defends that one spot
you're screwed
in technical terms
seventy years later sherman was to
relearn the lesson from experience by
reflection and coin his infamous maxim
about quote putting the enemy on the
horns of a dilemma
end quote in any problem where an
opposing force exists and cannot be
regulated one must foresee and provide
for alternative courses adaptability is
the law which governs survival and war
as in life
war being a concentrated war being but a
concentrated form of the human struggle
against the environment thank you
amplified
intensified but nonetheless
a concentrated form
of the human struggle
to be practical
any plan must take account of the
enemy's power to frustrate it
the best chance of overcoming such an
obstruction is to have a plan that can
be easily varied to fit the
circumstances
met i mean i just was saying this today
on ef online like you got to have a
flexible plan
you got to have a flexible plan and
you'd think that seems super obvious but
you know what you know what people want
to control
and they want to eliminate the unknown
and how do you eliminate the unknown you
come up with a plan
well guess what
they're still unknown even when you have
a plan and the more rigid
you make a plan the less adaptable and
flexible it becomes which is bad
to keep such adaptability while
keeping the initiative the best way is
to operate along a line which offers
alternative objectives
for thereby you put your opponent on the
horns of a dilemma
which goes
far to assure the gaining of at least
one objective whichever is the least
guarded and may enable you to gain the
other one afterwards
boom
in the tactical field where the enemy's
dispositions are likely to be based on
the nature of the ground it may be more
difficult to find a choice of
dilemma-producing objectives than it is
in the strategical field where the enemy
will have obvious industrial and railway
centers to cover but you can gain a
similar advantage by adapting your line
of effort to the degree of resistance
that is met and exploiting any
weaknesses is found
a plan like a tree must have branches if
it is to bear fruit a plan with a single
aim is apt to prove a barren pole
i'm just thinking of this idea of of
having multiple objectives and then the
dilemma that causes and even just in in
like aviation terms like we go out on a
mission and our objective is to destroy
enemy air defenses
sam sites or mobile sams whatever those
might be but it's actually reliant on
them
to have those systems active and
operating because how you find them if
they're shut down in the dormant you
actually can't find them they're not
radiating they're not uncovered you can
fly around and not have them there
but if they don't have their
sam systems or air defense systems
active then the things that they're
defending are vulnerable so the
secondary mission we'd have these things
called a tpl a target priority list if
these things aren't there cool go to
this those things aren't there cool go
to this and sooner or later one will be
exposed
and as you start to attack
those defended positions like bridges or
roads or things that matter better turn
on those radars turn on the radar that's
exactly right and
that idea that we would have multiple
target priorities which all eventually
are designed to lead us back to the
number one priority which might not get
on that mission but we get in the next
wave or the next wave and sooner or
later they're stuck in a place like well
if we don't turn these things on we're
going to lose all of our critical
infrastructure and there's nothing to
defend
and creating that dilemma by having
multiple objectives on each flight
yeah and in the business world this this
whole concept
is
we hear
um
we hear debates or arguments against
this right you got to have a clear
objective and that makes sense i tell
people that we got to make sure we
understand what the objective is
that being said we also don't want to
have a single point of failure
where hey you know what we're going to
put we're going to make one product yeah
we're going to make one product and if
this product does this product is the
one we're going to put all of our money
all of our
birds in this basket
eggs all our eggs are going to go in
this basket don't do that don't do that
don't put all your eggs in one basket
that's that's there you go never mind bh
liddell hart whichever farmer thought of
that one after his kid dropped the
the the basket full of eggs right he's
like hey kid don't put all your eggs in
one basket
put them in two baskets
same thing
it's the exact same thing yes sir
and yet we can get focused on one
objective
and as soon as you meet resistance if
you're not ready to switch to another
one like dave burke
flying you know up there and going home
there's nothing really to shoot at cool
what's the next objective bridges let's
go rock and roll
okay so now we're gonna roll a new
section called cutting communications in
planning any stroke at the enemy's
communications either by maneuver around
his flank or by rapid penetration of a
breach in his front the question will
arise as to the most effective point of
aim whether it should be directly
against
the immediate rear or the opposing of
the opposing force or further back when
studying the question so
again and i talked about this before uh
on the last podcast is
every time it talks about communications
it's an it's it's telling you hey you
better you better keep your
communication
open when we talk about attacking the
enemies communications and that's how we
cause unbalance and that's how we kind
of crush them great we're glad to know
that that's also a reminder to us as
leaders that communication is so
paramount to getting our job done
when he's got a whole section called
cutting communication guess what that
should mean to us from a red cell
perspective don't let your communication
get cut and yet we work with companies
all the time where the communication
isn't open and it's not flowing and
people on the front lines don't know
what's happening and the people in the
head shed don't get the feedback that
they should be getting from the front
lines there's not communication
happening
and yet there's a whole section here
about cutting communication and you're
allowing your communications to be cut
when there's not even an enemy it's not
like your competitor got into your email
system or got into your phone system and
didn't let you call your front line
leadership that didn't happen
you failed to do it
so
where do we cut the communication when
studying this question at the time that
experimental mechanized forces were
first created this and their strategic
use was under consideration i saw
guidance on it by anal by analysis of
cavalry raids carried out in the past
especially in the more recent wars since
railways came into use while such
cavalry raids had more limited
potentials than a deep strategic
penetration of mechanized forces seemed
to me to promise
that this difference emphasized rather
than detracted from making the
significant evidence which they provided
making the necessary adjustment the
following deductions could be drawn
and i'm going to kind of burn through
this section
the overall concept is that
the nearer to the force that the cut is
made the more immediate the effect
and the nearer to the base the greater
the effect it's common sense right if
you kill the
the node at the headquarters they can't
communicate to anybody
but it's going to take a while for that
impact to hit the front lines for them
to actually not know what's going on
whereas if you cut the front line node
that immediate node is kind of messed up
so that's the that's the general
consensus
that he gets into there
um
he goes on to say these deductions were
confirmed by the experience of the
second war above all the catastrophic
the catastrophically paralyzing effect
physically and psychologically that was
produced when great gordian's panzer
forces racing far ahead of the main
german armies severed the allied army's
communications where these crossed the
far back line of the psalm
and this is where you run into problems
so catastrophically paralyzing when we
start to cut off
communications so look are you going to
go into your competitors you know
headquarters and destroy their their
their internet and their email no you're
not going to do that but are you
allowing that to happen just by just by
human nature and laziness
and
no lack of prioritizing execute are you
going to allow your communications to
fall apart there's a decent chance you
are we work with companies all the time
that aren't communicating
they might as well have had
uh panzer forces go and cut off their
email between their front lines and them
because there's no email happening
there's no conference calls happening
there's no text happening we don't know
what's going on we've lost
communications not through enemy action
but through our own
fault yeah and and
one of the ways one of the places we see
that with business is that the
communication is a one-way communication
where i am
i am dictating or directing or
communicating to you i'm
transmitting and there's no response to
that transmission there's no
the communication really isn't designed
for me to hear what you have to say it's
for me to tell you what to do and how to
do it and when to do it and where to do
these things
and i get that compliance but i don't
get that communication which is a
a
almost guarantee that sooner or later
when then when there is friction with
that without that communication that
plan is going to fail um
even when i was just talking about
communication i said you're not getting
the you're not getting the information
the front lines and you're not getting
the feedback you need yeah which is what
you just said it's like hey
communication is supposed to go in two
ways that's what's supposed to be
happening if we don't let it happen
we're going to have problems
and in the in
making this relevant to to the civilian
world of the private sector
the the needle the bias needle of the
communication
would be to transmit as little as
possible
and and receive as much as possible
when i have when when i have my team
communicating to me more than i'm
committing to communicating to them
here's what we're seeing here's what
we're doing here's the problems we're
having here's how we're saying that's
what you would want that's how would you
you would set up the bias yes the biases
if i see that i'm the as the leader
doing 90 of the communication
the needle is in the wrong direction
and so the ability for my people to
communicate to me for me to hear from
them what they're doing what they're
seeing where they are
and i'm doing
less communicating to them than they are
communicating up to me that's where i
want that needle
that falls into something i was talking
about the other day on on our online
platform
i used this term and both it struck i
think both you and leif because you've
never heard me say it before i started
using the term traditional leadership
yeah and then like an archetypical
leadership
what does that mean well
when we think of a leader what do we
think of like if you just say oh what
does a leader do well a leader gives
orders a leader talks a leader tells
everyone what's going on they tell
people what to do that's traditional
leadership
and actually in my mind
if i'm doing that sort of traditional
leadership i've made 47 mistakes to get
to a point where i have to tell you
what's going on i have to give orders i
have to
uh give you direction about where to go
and what to do i've made so many
mistakes if i'm doing that traditional
leadership role of like all right here's
what we're doing
does that happen sometimes and that was
what i was talking about right the case
does sometimes happen where we got a
leadership vacuum no one knows what to
do there's some confusion and sometimes
we do have to take a role as a
traditional leader step in tell everyone
what to do this is what we're doing this
direction we're having heading
and in a traditional leadership role i'm
in charge i'm the one that's putting out
the word
we want to flip the script on that
to what to your point
traditional leadership
is not what my ideal is
ideal leadership
is dave's actually giving me information
and telling me what's going on and i
have to give very little communication
back because he already understands the
commander's intent and what his roles
were and he by the way knows more about
what's happening on his front than i do
totally and he's trying to inform me but
still he's there
so that that traditional leadership
versus ideal leadership
is
is something to pay attention to
and if you had whatever version of a
catastrophic communication failure
exists where you know it doesn't have to
be the phone lines in combat but some
something that prevents you from
communicating
if your people can't operate based on
your intent with zero communication and
just go out there and execute until
somehow that communication line is
reopened for whatever reason
that again that is a that is your
failure as a leader that they don't know
what to do if you're not there to tell
them what to do
so i don't you know in whatever world
you're in your version of a
communication cutoff
your people should still be able to
execute 100
next little section called the method of
advanced until the end of the 18th
century a physically concentrated
advance both strategic to the
battlefield and tactical on the
battlefield was the rule
then napoleon
exploiting borsei's ideas and new
divisional system introduced a
distributed strategic advance the army
moving in independent
but fractions
tactical advance was still in general a
concentrated one
this is you know we start getting into
decentralized command and you know i
mentioned borse already
b-o-u-r-c-e-t he's another french
general
um
1700s
i think he yeah born in 1700 died in
1780 but this is another guy that that
had a little bit of vision right
had a vision about decentralized command
and that's kind of one of them
this divisional system where you can
start to get people to move on their own
and that is a better way to advance
back to the book toward the end of oh
and by the way to dave's point
we know where we're going and if you
lose if if you got your division and
echo's got his division and carrie's got
his division and you lose columns with
me it doesn't matter three days later
you're where you're supposed to be
because you knew where you were going
yeah
back to the book towards the end of the
19th century with the development of
fire weapons the tactical advance became
dispersed i.e and particles to diminish
the effective fires this is when we
really start to get to dispersion
but the strategic advance had become
concentrated this would do partly to the
influence of railways and growth of the
masses
partly to the misunderstanding of the
napoleonic methods so when when we
started to use machine guns
well then people started dispersing
tactically but because of trains we were
moving these mass groups together
a revival of the distributed advance was
required in order to revive the art
and effective strategy moreover new
conditions air power and motor power
point to its further development into a
dispersed strategic advance
the danger of air attack the aim of
mystification and the need of drawing
full value from mechanized mobility
suggests that advancing forces should
not only be distributed as widely as as
is compatible with combined action but
be dispersed as much is compatible
with cohesion so what they're saying
there's a balance that you have to have
we got to be as far apart as we possibly
can
but as long as we're still a cohesive
unit
that's the dichotomy that you have to
balance
this becomes essential in the face of
atomic weapons obviously we can't be all
together because we're going to get
nuked
sure and it's crazy that we sit here and
chuckle at that
because for us it's almost like hey that
couldn't happen but
hey and we've covered we've covered uh
some significant military manuals where
they talk about the actual they're
planning on how they're gonna maneuver
when the enemy is using tactical nukes
which is crazy to think about
uh the development of radio has a timely
aid towards reconciling dispersion with
control
instead of the simple idea of
concentrated stroke
by a concentrated force we should choose
according to
circumstance between these variants it
gives some some op some some options
here dispersed advance with concentrated
single aim i.e against wanted objective
dispersed advance with concentrated
serial aim which which means when we get
there we're going to go off their
multiple successive objectives
dispersed advance with distributed aim
i.e against a number of objectives
simultaneously
the effectiveness of armies depends on
the development of such new methods
methods which aim at permeating and
dominating areas rather than capturing
lines
at the practicable
object of paralyzing the enemy's action
rather than the theoretical object of
crushing his forces
fluidity of forces may succeed where
concentration of force merely entails
rigidity a perilous
rigidity
so at times
bruce lee sure
we want to be like water
fluidity of force is
sometimes better than just concentration
of force if you can move jeff glover on
the jiu jitsu mats
you you grab
something on him and he's somewhere else
you grab something on dean
he's countering
right you grab something on
jeffy glover he's maneuvering like he's
gone it's like a
a piece of
sir yeah
you squeeze one part he pops out another
part
yes right with dean you can't squeeze
like it doesn't go anywhere he does the
squeezing yeah you're getting squeezed
that's the way it worked
all right
just the word fluid and i mentioned it
before i talk about fluid mutual support
just the idea of of being fluid is
its flexibility it's the ability to be
reactive to the situation in a way that
puts you in a place to be
available
to support as you need it but far enough
away to maneuver
as you need to and i just i think the
idea of
of in this era them talking about fluid
when the backdrop of world war one and i
know we've hit this a thousand times the
backdrop of world war one was
was whatever the opposite of fluid is
which is this
inca the inability
the inability to to to adjust to
maneuver to do something
you that that analogy you just did with
like that slime thing of i squeeze here
and something pops it over there that
the being the ability to be fluid
and
the the inherent
the the way you'd want to describe your
organization or your your reaction to
things going on in your organization
being fluid
and how quickly people get to being
rigid with their thought processes their
ideas their objectives what they want to
accomplish and how quickly it becomes
rigid
so so check this out we're in world war
one
okay we actually have a culture
that views fluidity
as weakness
the victorian culture if you want to run
away from danger you're a coward
you're weak
now take that and bring a thread to the
board room bring a thread to the
conference room and accompany and if
dave presents an idea to me
and i back down because i agree with his
idea or i back down because i oh i see
some holes in my idea i might be viewed
as weak
so i'm not going to be fluid instead i'm
going to be rigid i'm going to stand up
to dave we're going to fight about it
and by the way if i out rank you i'm
gonna win
it's freaking ridiculous crazy
but we have this culture
and and that culture you know look the
culture the reason that culture exists
especially the culture of rigidity
is directly tied to our human nature our
ego right because we feel like oh i
don't wanna i'm not gonna back down to
dave
i'm not gonna let that happen it's like
actually
you know what good call dave i like your
idea better
the the odd thing about this is that it
makes me look stronger
it makes me look open-minded and
flexible and confident to be like you
know what dave like your idea let's roll
with that
the whole room the whole freaking
conference room goes damn taco's got
some confidence he's good with whatever
plan he just wants us to win
as opposed to actually dave you know
what i've heard enough from you
we're going with my plan everyone in the
room goes oh he's weak
i think i'm strong i'm being weak and
everybody perceives me as weak
everybody pers this is the car one of
the hardest lessons to learn
it's one of the hardest lessons to learn
is that
flexibility
is viewed as a strength fluidity is
viewed as a strength putting your ego
and being humble is viewed as strength
and when you do the opposite when you're
rigid it's viewed as weakness when you
let your ego flare up it's viewed as
weakness it's viewed as insecurity
and we see this all day long
we see this all day long
check
next chapter
the concentrated essence
of
strategy and tactics
do i own royalties for my book do i i
think i kind of first i was like nah but
then now i think maybe to the to the um
to the children
and descendants of bhl dill heart
unfortunately for you this book was
published over 50 years ago so we are
cleared
and i apologize
but that's where we're at
hopefully people will buy this book and
you'll get some support it's uh
fantastic
this brief chapter is an attempt to
epitomize from the history of war and as
soon as you hear this dave you're going
to kind of be like oh here we go
this brief chapter is an attempt to
epitomize from the history of war a few
truths of experience which seems so
universal and so fundamental as to be
termed axioms
they are practical guides not abstract
principles napoleon realized that only
the practical is useful when he gave us
his maxims
but the modern tendency which we we'll
put i'm not gonna ask you we covered the
napoleon's maxims
on this podcast you can google it since
echo does not know nor do i
check
the modern tendency
has been to search for principles which
can be expressed in a single word
and then need several thousands words to
explain them
even so these principles are so abstract
that they may mean different things to
different men and for any value depend
on the individual's own understanding of
war the longer one continues to search
for such omnipotent abstra abstractions
the more do they appear a mirage neither
attainable nor useful except as an
intellectual exercise
these principles of war
not merely one principle can be
condensed into a single word
concentration so he's saying this word
concentration which we all learn
concentration of forces he's saying you
could say all these principles and put
them in the word concentration okay
let's start there but for the but for
truth
this needs to be amplified as
the concentration of strength against
weakness
and for any real value it needs to be
explained that the concentration of
strength against weakness depends on the
dispersion of your opponent's strength
which in turn is produced by a
distribution of your own that gives the
appearance and partial effect of
dispersion your dispersion his
dispersion your concentration such as
the sequence and equal and each is a
sequel
true concentration is a force of
calculated dispersion so he's saying
even though it's really easy to say
concentration it's like oh there's a lot
more going on than that yeah
here we have a fundamental principle
whose understanding may prevent a
fundamental error
and the most common that of giving your
opponent freedom and time to concentrate
to meet your concentration
this is why when you cover and move you
put down covering fire
and then the other element moves why
it's that covering fire that doesn't
allow the enemy to
maneuver to meet your concentration
but to state that the prince but to
state the principle is not much
practical aid for execution
the above mentioned axioms here
expressed as maxims cannot be condensed
into a single word but they can be put
into the fewest words necessary to be
practical eight in all
so far six are positive eight and all so
far it's interesting he's saying like
hey this is probably gonna change but
this is where we're at so far six are
positive and two are negative they apply
to tactics as well as strat strategy
unless otherwise indicated
number one
and these are the positive ones number
one
adjust
your end to your means
adjust your end to your means
this is another thing that's
you got to know your objective you got
to stick to your objective he's actually
saying look man you gotta make some
adjustments
your your end may change based upon your
means and here's what he says in
determining your object
clear sight and cool calculation should
prevail wouldn't that be nice
it is folly to quote bite off more than
you can chew
end quote and the beginning of military
wisdom is a sense of what is possible
that's the beginning of military wisdom
what's actually possible
and this is where you you know you can
get into some um
you know theoretical
ideas about but if you believe it it's
like no and it's actually interesting i
remember the early musters i got asked
about this and
i explained belief
as
seeing an actual pathway to victory
you you've got a belief means you can
actually see a an actual pathway a
viable pathway to achieve what you're
talking about
because to think you know what
i want to be an astronaut
like right now
i'm 49 years old
i guess i could figure out
no not really
i probably have a better chance of
becoming an astronaut than uh an nba
player
right same so is there okay same thanks
for the support bro
is there a viable pathway for me to
become an nba player not really
not really
so therefore i need to adjust the end a
little bit find something a little more
feasible
he goes on to say
so learn
so learn to face facts while still
pervert preserving faith
there will be ample need for faith the
faith that can achieve the apparent
impossible when action begins so look we
gotta have a positive attitude
confidence is like the current in a
battery avoid exhausting it in vain
effort
and remember that your own continued
confidence will be of no avail if the
cells of your battery the men upon
whom you depend have been run down
so this is a
again there's very few people that would
think that the military mind should
focus on hey
i might have to adjust what i'm trying
to get to
because it seems like the military is
you know like we're gonna get this done
like no
this is the number one
the number one axiom he's talking about
adjust your end to your means number two
keep your object always in mind now this
is a dichotomy right
keep your app your object always in mind
while adapting your plan to
circumstances
realize that there are more
we realize that there are more ways than
one of gaining an object an object but
take heed that every objective
should bear on the object
and in considering this
just just real quick
if you as a leader
can understand the fact
that there's more ways than one of
gaining an object your life just got a
thousand times more easy
just got a thousand times easier
i've seen
countless leaders
think that they know the way and want to
do something a certain way and waste
time and effort and resources and most
important waste leadership capital
to get something done a certain way when
my attitude is like i don't care
i don't care how you want to get this
done i don't care
this is what we want to get done how do
you want to do it cool sounds good it's
a viable plan
it's a minimally viable plan dave's plan
you know what i might do it differently
dave's plan looks like it could work too
cool and by the way
do we know your plan is going to work
perfectly no we don't do i know my plan
is going to work perfectly no we don't
so why am i going to invest a bunch of
resources and time and effort and
arguing and leadership capital trying to
convince you to use my plan instead of
your plan when they're both
a freaking gamble
don't waste your time
connecting connecting those two those
two i guess axioms together or those
those
those fundamental things from a
leadership standpoint
of and we even talked about this you
know from
as a leader showing people a path to the
to the end state that might not happen
today might happen tomorrow but it's
it's possible if you're gonna say hey
let's bring in the three of us we're
gonna we're gonna be a 100 million
dollar company
and i've got no way to show you
how that's going to happen other than uh
either
just belief or faith or or hope for a
miracle
um or
hey this one product this is gonna be
we're gonna have this magical product
and this is gonna work and
i could also say hey listen
our goal we want to be a 100 million
dollar company but let me tell you what
what's gonna what we're gonna have to do
right now we're not
but we're gonna do this and this
and that's gonna allow us to bring in
this other group maybe getting an
acquisition here and you can start to
lay out this path and people and i've
seen it in those rooms where you see the
leaders lay out the path to getting
there not the exact steps we're going to
take but what we and all of a sudden
people go oh oh
yeah we can we can do that and that's
going to lead to this and then we bring
in more people and we bring in more
resources we bring in
another company that does this just
laying out the steps
so people in their minds understand and
i and i'm just saying this because of
the word viable the the the
the value of people saying oh
that's actually not crazy what you're
saying is not this magic crazy pipe
dream i can actually see how if we do
this and then if i on that second step
as a subordinate leader understand what
you're trying to accomplish
and you're not here saying turn left to
your return right here do this and not
telling me what to do
or how to do it you're just telling me
the end state that we want
then i actually get to be the one that
drives us to that goal that is actually
so much more believable now because it's
viable because you laid that out and
then let me let me move towards that
objective here's a detail that i just
picked up on
taking what you said when you said uh
what i said back to me and i was like oh
there's an there's an error in what i
said
when i when i say a
belief is
seeing a path to victory what it should
actually be is
seeing paths plural to victory and the
reason i thought of this is because as
you're sitting here talking about well
if i say okay dave we're gonna make a
hundred million dollar company and you
go oh that sounds awesome i'm in yeah uh
but how are we gonna do that and i lay
out one single path to get us there
yeah you know that that's cool and
everything but your your faith in that
is gonna go down a little bit but if i
say hey listen here's our five different
lines of operations
and here's what each one of these things
are gonna produce and you know what
chances are dave one or two of these
might fail completely they're good ideas
i like them but we don't haven't gone
far enough down them to really
understand but
we know that of these ideas we have made
some progress in all of them and we see
potential so if two or three of these
paths go the way we want them to we're
going to be right where we want to be
we're going to get that 100 million so
even
you know going back to the last podcast
having multiple avenues of approach
is highly beneficial to your belief
system
being distributed and how you
go to an objective right yeah right
having more than one objective having
more than one pathway to that objective
yeah and by the way also saying look we
might we might not make this one
objective over here but we're still
going to get where we want to be
same maxim here continue on and in
considering possible objectives weigh
their possibility of attainment with
their service to the object if attained
to wander down a side track is bad but
to reach a dead end is worse
so
especially if the dead end is the only
pathway that you've got yeah that's why
having a couple different pathways is
smart number three choose the line or
course of least expectation
try to put yourself in the enemy's shoes
and think what course is least probable
he will foresee or forestall
number four exploit the line of least
resistance
so long as it can lead you to any
objective
which would contribute to your
underlying object
right oh yeah it's cool path least
resistance but it's got to be going in
the right direction
in tactics this maximum applies to the
use of your reserves and in strategy the
exploitation of tactical success
number five
take a line of operation which offers
alternative objectives okay sorry we
went a little ahead on that one
for you will thus put your opponent on
the horns of dilemma which comes from
the last podcast which goes far to
assure the chance of gaining one
objective at least whichever he guards
least and may enable you to gain one
after the other because once you get one
like we make it in one line of operation
and now we made a bunch of money cool
guess what we can invest in that other
thing that was a little bit harder out
of the gate but now we have the money to
spend on it and we can make it happen
yeah
alternative objectives allow you to keep
the opportunity of gaining an objective
whereas a single objective unless the
enemy is helplessly inferior means the
certainty that you will not gain it once
the enemy is no longer uncertain as to
your aim as soon as the enemy knows what
you're doing your chances of success go
down dramatically unless they're
helplessly inferior
there is no more common mistake than to
confuse a single line of operation which
is usually wise with a single objective
which is usually futile
number six and the last of the positive
maxims
ensure that both plans and dispositions
are flexible
adaptable to circumstances
and by dispositions that's like where
you're putting people
your plans should foresee and provide
for a next step in case of success or
failure or a partial success which is
the most common case in war your
dispositions or formation should be such
as to allow this exploitation or
adaptation in the shortest possible time
you know people people will argue and
fight and struggle with trying to figure
out how they're going to task organize
organize a group of people like well no
actually dave i think this person should
report to dave and this person should
report to leif and this person should
report to me we can argue about that
stuff i'll wait all day long
and by the way you're pissed i'm pissed
and guess what
it's our company
and i go you know what dave you go ahead
that person can report you cool that
sounds good and you look up at me in two
weeks and you're like hey
this doesn't really make much sense okay
cool they can report you know like
you don't it's not set in stone you
don't get a tattoo on your forehead of
your task organization
and by the way it doesn't look quote
look bad to say hey you know what fred
you're gonna be working for dave and
then a month later say hey fred seems
like your expertise is really gonna be a
little bit more beneficial to leif and
what he's got going on we're gonna shift
you over there
no do you want to do this every two
weeks no obviously not
but to put someone in a position
or or task organize organize in a
certain way
and and have it flexible
flexible dispositions that's exactly
what it is is the smart way to do things
and obviously it's with a flexible plan
as well
the negatives
do not throw your weight into a stroke
whilst your opponent is on guard whilst
he is well placed to parry or evade it
the experience of history shows that
save against a much inferior opponent no
effective stroke is possible until his
power of resistance or evasion is
paralyzed
hence no commander should launch a real
attack upon an enemy in position until
satisfied that such a paralysis has
developed it is produced by
disorganization and its moral equivalent
demoralization of the enemy so
cool set it up
set up the move
eight and the last one do not renew an
attack along the same line or in the
same form after it has once failed
a mere reinforcement of weight is not a
sufficient change for it is probable
that the enemy also will have
strengthened itself in the interval it
is even more probable that his success
in repulsing you will have strengthened
immorally um
it's one of my favorite coaching moves
in jiu jitsu
is uh you know
do it harder i was i was saying that to
carry the other day
like he's like grabbing your wrist i
could grab that thing harder
it hasn't helped him for six minutes
grabbing the wrist while he's in your
guard but if he does it harder you know
that might work that's what this is like
it didn't work it's not gonna work don't
do it harder
just because you add hey you know we
spent a bunch of money on advertising
uh we haven't seen any bump
in our in our uh
uh sales yeah spend more let's spend
more
i guess the only thing that surprised me
is
from the guy who was in world war one
that that wasn't number one
yeah like the first thing he says is hey
don't do what we did for three straight
years yeah
maybe that's why it's his last point
yeah
like hey by the way you freaking idiot
idiots
all this other stuff cool
listen you freaking idiots if it doesn't
work don't keep doing it
if it didn't work with ten thousand men
it's not gonna work with twenty thousand
that's crazy
you can see how you get sucked into that
don't you yeah you're like you know what
the way you get sucked into it is when
you commit yourself to the outcome of
your plan
this plan is going to achieve this
outcome
and if i
if i allocate resource i work for you
hey this is the plan is we're going to
do i allocate resources and doesn't work
well i can either abandon that plan make
me look weak like oh or i can go hey
we're going to allocate more resources
and more resources and more resources
more resources because i'm inflexible to
say well actually maybe i didn't connect
my ends to my means to the end and i
didn't do just something might need to
do something different or regroup or
reassess or
come in from a different direction
as opposed to saying hey you know what
that hey boss that plan didn't work let
me take a step back we need to kind of
see what we what we did here with this
marketing scheme it didn't have the
effect that we want and before we start
putting in more resources let me get a
better assessment of what's going on and
kind of give that to you and it may be
that we do the same thing
but we're probably going to need to make
some changes
yeah at least quantify your efforts
right
it's really disturbing because it really
is one of these things where
it is so tempting
when you get close you get you know you
feel like the pressure like you try an
arm lock and you almost got it you try
it again it's like the person defended
it once the person is going to defend it
again you spend that money in marketing
you spend that money
and you you know you saw a little bit of
an uptick but it's not quite what you
wanted but still maybe we just put more
money into it
and i'm listening i'm listening to you
talk about some of those things and i'm
almost trying to think of of
what is the human nature to do that and
i think some of it is is
we kind of glorify
this
single-minded this yeah
i think it's similar things we
there's like this glorification of
i refuse to give in i refuse to to to
give up i refuse to tap i refuse to
accept defeat
and
so my answer is i'm just going to send
more i'm going to send more and more and
i think the times that that perseverance
pays off there's some sort of like
glorification of that single-mindedness
when when in in reality
how
much weaker does it make us look by
being unwilling to say
hang on
i think there's a flaw in my plan here
let me let me just
i need i need to take a step back and
rethink this i'm i'm missing something
i'm missing something
and
the weakness that that shows and you
were talking about before is you know
that makes you look weak when the exact
opposite is true
yeah well
i have a section in leadership strategy
and tactics called when to quit
never quit actually
totally wrong
when do you quit oh this plan that we
have is not working we lost a guy two
guys three guys this is stupid let's go
a different direction
now just imagine doing that
for battalions and brigades and
divisions of soldiers man it's free for
you crazy it is crazy
just give us a look we just had if we
just would have had another 10 000
soldiers at that moment
god it's so tempting
is it like do you feel like it's maybe
like because it's like you say glorify
um
you know never quite that yeah that
never quit and then they over over
simplify it because you say persistence
right persistence always you know like
that's the way this guy was successful
he's just persistent you know fail fail
and by the way dichotomy right yeah it's
a dichotomy like you can say oh you know
what it didn't work the way we wanted to
okay screw it we're gonna go do
something else like so there's a
dichotomy in this right you know even
when i was talking about like you go for
the arm lock you don't get it you go for
the arm lock you don't get it there's
plenty of fights where the person went
for the arm lock three four times
finally they get it yeah that's what i'm
saying where they oversimplify it where
they have all these cool sayings like
you know if if at first you don't
succeed you know try again or you know
all these things but there's more to it
than that something else yeah some of
the pacific island campaign
hey we should be done with this
operation in three days cool
19 days later we're not even a quarter
wave where we're supposed to be
like guess what
we're going to send some more resources
there we're going to get it done oh man
that's why this is even this is a
dichotomy totally
yes so the persistence and the you know
if at first you don't succeed try and
try again or whatever the
it's
persistent not in the same exact
methodology it's like persistence but
you kind of got to make these little
changes within that but you can't really
fit that in the little slogan you know a
lot of the time
i was just gonna say i mean in very
simplistic terms
you know i think that's
one of the differences between the
tactics and the strategy is i will
abandon a tactic
and i will give up on a tactic very
quickly if it if it's the wrong tactic
to get to the now
giving up on a strategy is a very
different thing
but giving up on the tactic or or
maybe it's not even the right word but
adjusting my tactics
and adjusting the plan and getting
feedback from the ones implementing the
plan while sticking to the strategy or
the or the long-term objective again
very simplistically but the commitment
to the tactic when you see people
committing to the same thing over and
over and over again as opposed to going
hey this tactic isn't working is there a
better way to do this to accomplish that
same end goal of what we want to become
as a company or as a team
um
that difference for me is how often we
see people unwilling to change their
tactic yeah when it's so obvious that
they need to and that's the exact that's
exactly
in that section in leadership strategy
and tactics once i explain like hey
you need to quit what you're doing
that's failing this doesn't mean you
abandon your overall strategy that's the
actual words that i use i open it up but
that's because that's that's 100 right
just because i go oh you know what this
doesn't seem to be working right look
when when in world war one it wasn't hey
this isn't working let's surrender no
it's you know what this isn't working
let's figure out a different way to do
this
let's figure out a different way to
attack
i think it's also just a freaking sanity
check that you need to do it's neat it's
one of these things where look you beat
your i
i used to say this on the podcast uh
my limit for beating my head against the
wall is 47 times like once i've beat my
head against the wall 47 times like okay
number 44 45
46.
okay 47 this isn't going to work i got
to try something else like you got to
check yourself what is that number how
much you how much money are you willing
to throw into marketing how big how many
more people are you willing to give to
that leader that's failed yeah uh how
many more projects are you you know like
there's things where you've got to check
yourself is it have you beat your head
against the wall 47 times any of your
head have
don't go the 48th time
time to re-evaluate your your tactic
doesn't mean you need to abandon what
you're trying to do means you need to
freaking check yourself
um back to the book the essential truth
underlying these maxims is that for
success two major problems must be
solved dislocation and exploitation
one precedes and one follows the actual
blow
which in comparison is a simple act so
it's pretty easy to hit him
but you got to set up the hit and you
got to exploit the hint once you've done
you cannot hit the enemy with effect
until you have first created the
opportunity you cannot make that effect
decisive unless you exploit the second
opportunity that comes before he can
recover
the pos the importance of these two
problems has never been adequately
recognized a fact which goes far to
explain the common indecisiveness of
warfare
so we don't make decisions because we
don't understand how important it is
that when echoes off balance i better
freaking attack or before i get them off
balance i need to set them up so i can
get them off balance
the training of armies this is freaking
epic the training of armies is primarily
devoted to developing efficiency in the
detailed execution of the attack
the concentration on tactical technique
tends to obscure the psychological
element it fosters
a cult of soundness rather than surprise
it bleeds it breeds commanders who are
so intent not to do anything wrong
according to the book
that they forget the necessity of making
the enemy do something wrong
the result is that their plans have no
result
[Music]
for in war it is by compelling mistakes
that the scales are most often turned
gotta make the person make mistakes
here and there a commander has eschewed
the obvious
and is found in unexpected in the
unexpected the key to a decision
unless fortune has proved foul for luck
can never be divorced from war since
it's part of life
hence
the unexpected cannot guarantee success
but it guarantees the best chance of
success that's why we got to surprise
people
next section the national
object and military aim and
look we talk about alignment a lot and
this is where inside of an organization
this is this is really talking about
alignment and so as you you as you hear
us discuss this thinking about alignment
through your organization
this is what we have to be
cognizant of as leaders
in discussing the subject of the
objective in war it is essential to be
clear about and keep clear in our minds
the distinction between the political
and military objective
the two are different but not separate
for nations that for nations do not wage
war for war's sake but in pursuance of
policy the military objective is only
the means to a political end hence the
military objective should be governed by
the political objectives subject to the
basic condition that policy does not
demand what is militarily that is
practically impossible
so what are we trying to do in our
company
what are we actually trying to do inside
of our company and if we're trying to do
something inside of our company does
everybody on the team understand what
we're trying to do and are there
maneuvers out there
in support of what it is we're trying to
do
thus any study of the problem ought to
begin and end with a question of policy
the term objective
although common usage
is not really a good one it has a
physical and geographical sense and thus
tends to confuse thought it would be
better to speak of the object
when dealing with the purpose of policy
and of the military aim when dealing
with the way that forces are directed in
the service of policy
so i mentioned on the first podcast we
did that he kind of goes into this
objective versus object and he uses the
term object i think it's not it's a
little bit of an archaic way of using it
i know it's only 19 whatever 30.
but for us we use objective
all the time
and we definitely use it in a military
sense but to his point objective we
think of like airfield
right we think of beachhead
so maybe it's a good idea we'll go with
it
the object in war
is a better state of peace
even if only from your own point of view
this is a you know i always talk about
climbing the ladder of alignment this is
the highest you can get in the ladder of
alignment for war
the reason we're in war is because we
want a better piece that's what we're
trying to do
hence it is essential to conduct war
with constant regard for your for the
peace you desire
this is the long long long term thinking
that applies to both both to aggressor
nations who seek expansion and to
peaceful nations who only fight for
self-preservation although their views
of what is meant by a better state of
peace are very different history shows
that gaining military victory is not
in itself equivalent to gaining the
object of policy
but as most of the thinking about war
has been done by men of the military
profession there has been a very natural
tendency to lose the site of basic
national object and identify it with the
military aim
so how does this happen inside of a
business we start the business the
people that are out there in the field
trying to make things happen they might
lose sight of what it is we're trying to
do
and consequence whenever war is broken
out policy is too often been governed by
the military aim and this has been
regarded as an end in itself instead of
as a merely a means to an end
fast forward a little bit for more than
a century of the prime cannon of
military doctrine has been that has been
that
quote the destruction of the enemy's
main forces on the battlefield
constituted the only true aim in war
that's what war is for
just destroy the enemy destroy the enemy
forces on the battlefield actually that
was universally accepted engraved in all
military manuals and taught at all staff
colleges if any statesman ventured to
doubt whether it fitted the national
object in all circumstances he was
regarded it was regarded as blasphemy
and violating holy writ as can be seen
in studying the official records and
memoirs of the military heads of the
warring nations particularly in and
after world war one
so absolute a rule would have astonished
the great commanders and teachers of war
theory and ages prior to the 19th
century for they had recognized the
practical necessity of wisdom of
adapting aims to limitations of strength
and policy
like how long are we gonna try and fight
this thing before i say you know what
this is freaking not good
we're expending all of our national
treasure and we're not getting anywhere
this is a bad call
and now we're going to start hammering
on crossfits again
klaus fitz's
influence the rule acquired its dogmatic
rigidity largely through the posthumous
influence of klaus wits and his books
upon the minds of prussian soldiers
particularly mulkey
and thence more widely through the
impact of their victories in 1866 and
1870 made upon the armies of the world
which copied so many features of the
prussian system
thus it is a vital importance to examine
his theories
as so often happens
klaus wits his disciples carried his
teachings to an extreme which their
master had not intended
misinterpretation has been the common
fate of most prophets and thinkers in
every sphere devout but uncompromising
oh sorry devout but uncomprehending
disciples have been more damaging to the
original conception than even its
prejudiced and per-blind opponents
so what what happens we get people that
take things to the extreme
and they do more damage than the people
that are against the idea
it must be admitted however that klaus
wits invited misinterpretation more than
most
sorry klaus fitz
a student of kant
at
second hand he acquired a philosophical
mode of expression without developing a
truly philosophical mind ouch
sorry dude he's hammering close what's
there consonants is taking heavies
how are you how did you guys talk about
crossfits in a positive way in policy
school or mostly i mean
the the the pull from klaus was to the
takeaway from that was there were
components inside there that
the things that he said
make sense and and
he talks about ends and meads he talks
about tactics and strategy and is really
a good tool for people to understand
and the way the context that we're using
is actually i think very important and
very similar to what he's saying is that
the military which has this
sort of outsized recognition this
outsize um
uh status of the the the
instead of being a tool to accomplish
the political means of what the state
wants it it's almost uh
it means in and of itself as if the
military exists for the military as
opposed to this is a tool one of many
tools
that actually accomplishes the political
means which and
to just kind of bring that back a little
bit when he talked about
the
object being
a greater piece or a better piece or or
whatever the term that you use and it's
funny because i think i've evolved in my
thinking when i hear objective i don't
think bridge anymore i don't think
airfield anymore i think goals i think
outcomes so but i understand his point
and i certainly remember in the
beginning of my military career what's
the objective oh to secure that bridge
or or to to do whatever that particular
thing is
if we've got a company and our company's
object or our vision our goal is to be
you know the premier hardware producer
for a product that every company in the
world needs for them to be successful
and then i've got a sales team inside
there and everything well sales is like
the most important thing we have we got
to sell this thing it's the military
version for this company and you're out
there running the sales team and your
objective is sell as many of these
things as you can
because that's obviously how we become
the indispensable producer of this
product that everybody's going to need
and be the most reputable and reliable
company in the world
but if you're out there selling this
product
and it hasn't been made yet because our
operations team hasn't stood up
or
you're selling this and we don't have
the support for the clients that are
going to buy it to actually give them
the tools they need or you're selling
this and we don't have the software to
update it and back it up
you can actually accomplish your
objective by selling this product
that doesn't help us achieve the object
that doesn't actually help us be
successful
and
i'm not defending kosovo's but there is
the military has something somebody's
got yeah it's all good
the the military
in some ways has become
this tool this means that sort of in and
of itself is its own thing like the
military exists to defeat you know to
win wars and defeat the enemy and
destroy battlefields once actually no
it's one of several different ways and
when you made that comment about the
military's existence like the ideal
thing you would think for the military
is i want this military to exist
to deter any potential opponent from
ever going to war with us
in terms of like what would i want from
a military i don't want i would love to
never set foot on the battlefield i'd
love to never get now whether or not
that's realistic but i would love a
military force of people our opponents
look look at and go
you know what i'm good with your plan i
like your plan i'm here to support that
plan you want to use our our bridges and
roads to for commerce
and maybe occupy some of my towns yeah i
let's find a compromise to make that
work as opposed to no this isn't going
to happen and your military shows up to
compel me to do it in a way that i don't
necessarily want but the object
objective thing
and i'm just trying to make the
connection to
to the business world of
if you think you're out there just to do
this one thing and it doesn't support
the object of the company or the
long-term goal
you're actually not successful you're
not winning i sold the most product cool
can we support it no can we build it no
can we back it up no can can the clients
get what they want no
then then we actually aren't successful
what happens to our reputation what
happens to our backlog we get crushed
and and you're gonna see he he
he goes he goes relatively hard on
crosswords he also
explains some of the things that people
missed which he he kind of also blames
on klaus wits
but
there's a lot of things that klaus with
says in the uh
that just aren't as memorable
that aren't as memorable as some of his
really
kick-ass statements and people remember
what sounded cool yeah and if they got
mistaken like i think however many
chapters are in on war i think he wrote
like the first three by himself and
they're really well written and super
complete and then
several chapters were written by his
wife after he died and they're like half
done and like
and they've been
you know hearts probably wrote this in
english and colossus was written in some
sort of prussian version that's been
translated a thousand times so again
yeah in his defense
yeah and when you do that translation if
you kind of think that maybe uh you know
concentration and mass is how to win you
definitely are going to emphasize that i
think this is what he meant and yeah
back to the book his theory of war was
expounded in a way too abstract and
involved for ordinary soldier minds
essentially concrete he's saying the
soldier mines are concrete to follow the
course of his argument which often
turned back from the direction in which
it was apparently leading impressed yet
before
they grasped at his vivid leading
phrases seeing only their surface
meaning and missing the deeper current
of his thought
klauswick's greatest contribution to the
theory of war was in emphasizing the
psychological factors raising his voice
against the geometrical school strategy
then festival he showed that the human
spirit was infinitely more important
than operational lines and angles he
discussed the effect of danger and
fatigue the value of boldness and
determination with deep understanding
it was his errors however which had the
greatest effect on subsequent course of
history
he was too continental in his outlook to
understand the meaning of sea power and
his vision was short on the very
threshold of the mechanical era he did
he declared his conviction that
superiority in numbers becomes every day
more decisive yeah so he kind of was a
little bit late they didn't freaking
tank yet
one of the classic discussions was the
the um
what's the word i'm looking for
the relevance of costs was in the 21st
century you know start talking about you
know like nuclear power your nuclear
weapons stealth airplanes and things
like hey do these maxims of these do
these do they hold up to the scrutiny of
the 21st century of warfare the modern
warfare and a bunch of discussions on
that
i kind of chuckled at the idea of like
his disciples the klaus was disciples
who kind of aren't that smart but really
like what he had to say you know that'd
be like me reading leadership strategy
tactics and there's a chapter that says
don't care
and me be like hey everybody don't care
yeah but getting that wrong but
misunderstanding like i don't care as
opposed to
i don't care how we do it you want to do
area i don't care we'll do it your way
which is a little bit different than
don't care next thing you know dave
burke jocko's disciple is running around
telling all the rest of his people we
don't care yeah and i don't care yeah i
don't care and we're now a bunch of
people who don't care and how easy you
could see a disciple who's
and i i'll never remember the quote but
the the most damage was done by
um the concrete brain well you said the
disciples that the misunderstanding of
his disciples did way more damage than
the opponents right right because i'm
running around espousing jocko's you
know edicts but actually don't really
know what he meant by don't care yeah
and i'm just using that one example of
kind of pulling from this book of like a
great way of like i don't care
like dude that that is not what he meant
i know that's what it says on paper but
that's not what he was saying yeah or
like knowing to quit hey man you know
what you gotta throw in the towel
whatever we quickly give up shut it down
yeah
uh uh so he's talking about how
important oh well i know what i was
gonna say i i was taking a note when you
were writing i only got down the two
letters m a and then i was looking i was
like what the hell was i going to write
i was going to write machine gun
because for me
where the tactics sort of solidified
where you can say yep these things hold
up it's you got to have the machine gun
that's where we start to get the modern
machine gun where we can start to kill a
lot of people and how concentration is
like the war is the worst thing and just
cover and move becomes totally important
it's it's important in all eras but it
really starts to solidify around there
well you use the example of like on
steroids of nuclear weapons you know you
talk about dispersion you know versus
concentration with with nuclear weapons
um i thought of another one just as i
was thinking of it as
hold the line jaco says hold the line
cool
got it yeah we're gonna hold the line
and look what we're talking about is the
story behind the book the dichotomy of
leadership the dichotomy of leadership
is chapter 12 in extreme ownership so
cool we covered it why do we have to
write a whole new book because people
still like extreme ownership
we gotta hold the line
it's disciplined and all kinds like they
took everything to the extreme and
that's why the story of the patches at
muster is so powerful because people are
like oh this is gonna be awesome
jaco is going to hammer that platoon and
destroy them for violating his direct
order to never wear patches that aren't
professional he's like not in care no
factor like wait what
it says right there hold the line yeah
it's like yeah but actually living in
the extremes isn't actually doesn't work
yes it usually doesn't work but the
title of the book is extreme ownership
yeah so well there you go there's
perfect examples that's what happened to
klaus fitz and he didn't even get to
finish his book he wrote freaking three
chapters
and his old lady finished it up
uh
such a commandment gave reinforcement to
the instinctive conservatism of soldiers
in resisting the possibilities of a new
form of superiority which mechanical
invention increasingly offered it also
gave powerful impulse to the universal
extension and permanently permanent
establishment of
the method of constrict conscription as
a simple way of providing the greatest
possible numbers
so if you want a big army
if i want to be in charge of a bunch of
people you know what i have to say look
we need more people if we're going to
win cool start drafting people i want to
be in charge of more people cool draft
more people
this by its disregard for psychological
suitability meant that armies became
much more liable to panic and sudden
collapse the earlier method however
unsystematic had at least tended to
ensure that the forces were composed of
good fighting animals
[Music]
this is an interesting shot at klaus
switz klaus wits contributed no new or
strikingly progressive ideas to tactics
or strategies
he was a codifying thinker rather than a
creative or dynamic one he had no such
revolutionary effect on warfare as the
theory of the divisional system produced
in the 18th century or the theory of
armored mobility in the 20th which by
the way
that's what kind of ledell heart like is
about right so he said look cosmos
didn't do anything compared to the
theory of armored mobility whoever came
up with that yeah
well i feel bad i actually feel bad
talking about these guys talking is that
weird i didn't know how much of a of a
hammer he was going to be on klaus the
cool thing is i'm hearing all this but
but i mean there is a lot of
i understand what he's saying
i mean
yeah
and again
why didn't i we're 286 episodes deep in
this and i haven't covered one of the
most respected and well-known canons of
military strategy yeah klaus switz is on
war why is that this is kind of why yeah
oh boy i'm gonna catch some grief for
this one yup
going out just getting crazy well what's
interesting is that i think if you were
kind of just pulse a bunch of
it doesn't have to be historians that
are civilians but if you look at what
the military and sort of key policy
makers study
klaus woods is higher on that list than
heart oh you know what i mean
so for sure
not even the same ballpark you may get
some heat because if there's someone
that's been studied and sort of kind of
lionized
klaus woods is the guy you know what i
mean so yeah there's some people out
there going hey well you know i've taken
some heat over the years i had a little
guy named colonel david hackworth who
was a complete black sheep of the army
and hated by the navy totally and i was
in the navy
talking about that guy
um
back to the book but in seeking to
formulate the experience of the
napoleonic wars the emphasis he put on
certain retrograde retrograde features
helped to cause what might be termed a
revolution in reverse back towards
tribal warfare
klaus was theory of the military aim in
defining the military aim
klaus which was carried away by his
passion for pure logic
quote
[Music]
the and this this makes it really uh
this starts to make it really obvious
why this stuff doesn't mend with my
normal way of thinking
quote the aim of all action in war is to
disarm the enemy and we shall now show
that this in theory at least is
indispensable if our opponent is to be
made to comply with our will we must
place him in a situation where which is
more oppressive to him than the
sacrifice we demand but the
disadvantages of this position must
naturally not be of a transitory nature
at least in appearance otherwise the
enemy instead of yielding will hold out
in the hope of a change for the better
every change in this position which is
produced by a continuation of war must
therefore be a change for the worse
worse the worst condition in which a
belligerent can be placed is that of
being completely disarmed if therefore
the enemy is to be reduced to into
submission he must either be positively
disarmed or placed in such a position
that he is threatened with it
from this follows that the complete
disarming or overthrow of the enemy must
always be the aim of warfare
end quote
this reminds me of uh
the bath party in iraq being completely
disarmed how much did that help
freaking hurt right
um
maybe some klaus whitsey and people were
saying yep gotta disarm him yeah
completely completely good job
the influence of of kant kant where's
where's daryl cooper daryl cooper is
making jokes about like he's just
bringing in deep echo and i are looking
at him like bro wrong crowd
the influence of kant can be perceived
in klaus wit's dualism of thought
he believed in a perfect military world
of ideals while recognizing a temporal
world in which these could only be
imperfectly fulfilled so he's giving
credit here's a little credit going back
to klaus where it's like hey man he got
it that you got these ideals but it's
the real world and it's not going to
quite go that well for he was capable of
distinguishing between what was what was
militarily ideal and what he described
as a modification in the reality thus he
wrote reasoning in the abstract the mind
cannot stop short of an extreme
but everything takes a different shape
when we pass from abstractions to
reality
this object of war in the abstract the
disarming of the enemy is rarely
attained in practice and is not a
condition necessary to peace so he
wasn't even saying what he was saying he
goes back and kind of backs off it a
little bit
koswitz's tendency to the extreme is
shown again in his discussion of battle
as a means to an to the end of war
he opened with the startling assertion
there is only one single means it is the
fight
he justified this by a long argument to
show that in every form of military
activity
quote the idea of fighting must
necessarily be at the foundation end
quote
having elaborately proved what most
people would be ready to accept without
argument klaus which said the object of
a combat is not always the destruction
of enemy forces its object can often be
attained as well without the combat
taking place at all so there you go he's
saying some of the stuff that
that i do agree with
moreover klaus wits recognized that
quote the waste of our own military
forces
must
ceteris paribus
which means all things being equal
always be greater the more our aim is
directed upon the destruction of the
enemy's power
the danger lies in this that the greater
efficacy which we
which we seek recoils on ourselves and
therefore has worse consequences in case
we fail of success so he's got some
he's got some quantifying statements
about his
about his thoughts and theories
out of his own mouth klaus wits here
gave a prophetic verdict upon the
consequences of of following his own
gospel in world war one and two for it
was the ideal and not the practical
aspect of his teachings on battle which
survived he contributed to this
distortion by arguing it was only to
avoid the risks of battle that quote any
other means are taken
so it's like we're trying to avoid
battle that's the only reason that we're
going to do anything else because we're
trying to avoid battle and he fixed the
distortion in the minds of his pupils by
hammering on the abstract ideal
and this is
here's our i guess i guess uh liddell
heart's just gonna go hot on everybody
he says not one reader and a hundred was
likely to follow the subtlety of his
logic or to preserve a true balance amid
such philosophical jugglery
but everyone could catch such ringing
phrases as and here's where he gets a
the branded the the klaus wits branded
statements that that are uh click bait
here we go and they're freaking good to
go like you hear me like yeah
we have only one means in war the battle
the bloody solution of the crisis the
effort for the destruction of the
enemy's forces is the firstborn son of
war i mean come on dude if you're in the
military you're eating these things up
like
like a giant nice cool mulk
only great and general battles can
produce great results
let us hear not of generals who conquer
without bloodshed right that's a that's
a quote from a guy that earlier was
saying like hey listen you don't always
want to go to war yeah but but who
remembers hey sometimes you can use
other means to achieve victory i don't
want to hear that they want to hear let
us not hear of great generals who
conquer without bloodshed
so he branded himself but man
by the reiteration of such phrases klaus
wits blurred into the outlines of his
philosophy already indistinct and made
it into mere marching refrain
um
which in inflamed the blood and
intoxicated the mind in transfusion it
became a doctrine fit to form corporals
not generals
for by making battle appear quote the
only real warlike activity
end quote his gospel deprived strategy
of its laurels and reduced the art of
war to the mechanics of mass slaughter
moreover it incited generals to seek
battle at the first opportunity instead
of creating an advantageous opportunity
cosworth contributed to the subsequent
decay of general ship
oh man
when he when in an oft-quoted passage he
wrote
philanthropists
may easily imagine that there is a
skillful method of disarming and
overcoming the enemy without great
bloodshed and that is the proper
tendency of the art of war that is an
error which must be
extirpated
so like hey this idea of bloodshed we
gotta get rid of that idea
that you can that you can
have war without bloodshed you gotta get
rid of that idea
it is obvious that when he wrote that he
did not pause to reflect that what he
decried had been recorded as the proper
aim of generalship by all masters of the
art of war including napoleon himself
like everyone sun tzu napoleon everyone
in between like hey man if you can win
without fighting that's what we're doing
and he's saying the opposite
klaus woods phrase would henceforce be
used by countless blunderers to excuse
and even justify their futile
squandering of life in bullheaded
assaults
the danger was increased because of the
way he constantly dwelt on the decisive
importance of a numerical superiority
with deeper penetration he pointed out
in one passage that surprise
lies quote at the foundation of all
undertakings for without it the
preponderance at the decisive point is
not properly conceivable
so that's what we're talking about
that's cool that's maneuver warfare but
his disciples struck by his more
frequent emphasis on numbers came to
regard mere mass as the simple recipe
for victory
horrible
and you know what what's a similar idea
to that is like my rank right it's a
rank hey i outrank you that's my
superiority and that's what i'm going to
use to lead
i mean that was
that was brutal yeah that was kind of a
brutal
there's there's some little statements
that was like hey he also said this but
it's like
uh when the general reads it
when the soldier reads it what does he
want to read he wants to read about
kicking ass yeah
and what does he want his corporals to
read he wants his corporals to read
about kicking ass so what do we start
reading about kick and ass yeah
we hear what we want to hear echo
charles yes sir
we're not done yet with call so it's
klaus what's theory of the object even
worse was the effectiveness theoretical
exposition
and exaltation of the idea of absolute
warfare income in proclaiming that the
road to success was through the
unlimited application of force
thereby a doctrine which began by
defining war only as a continuation of
state policy by other means led to the
contradictory end of making policy the
slave of strategy and bad strategy at
that
you know that's i would say that's one
of his most famous
quotes right is that war is a
continuation of state policy by other
means
but
he he
he ends up taking things to a point
where it's like war is what we're doing
like you said what the military exists
for the military that everything else
exists because of the military yeah the
government is here to provide the
military with the resources that we need
to go fight battles
the trend was fostered above all by his
dictum that quote to introduce into
philosophy of war a principle of
moderation would be an absurdity
war is an act of violence pushed to its
utmost bounds dude he's getting some
good quotes therefore they sound kick
ass
unless you're a freaking soldier in
world war one yeah
the crazy thing is i'm as i'm just kind
of picturing this i mean i'm asking
myself now a question that i probably
should have asked five years ago 10
years ago when i was thinking about this
on a more academic mind of of
how did klauswitz
or any of these people that are i guess
disciples of that of that kind of pure
logic train
how did they perceive
the value of their own people
you know because you could see the train
of thought of like hey the this is the
the
the purpose of the military is the utter
destruction or what you know those those
quotes
where's the the
the you could make a very easy link of
like hey my soldiers they're just
implementing tools they're just
resources to be expended to achieve that
end state and how quickly you can make
the the stretch like in world war one
you can almost imagine like
yeah they're not they're not people
they're resources they just give me 10
000 more resources or more tools to
accomplish this thing yeah i
i mean you kind of phrased that as a
question i don't think there's much of a
question for sure i think it's pretty
obvious where
where these guys were coming from
and it's it's it's really scary that you
had a culture that supported that
and you had
you know uh
you know it's like it's it's really
strange or you think about like kipling
and and kipling who wrote these very
patriotic poems
that fueled this culture inside of
england
and
his son was killed in in world war one
and like the last thing they saw of him
was he's blinded and he's kind of like
stumbling on the battlefield before he
was killed in his body i don't think
they ever even recovered his body just
lost in the mud and muck
and he's got a really
harrowing poem
i think i i i know the phrase of the
poem is is
my boy jack or my son jack it's it's
it's harrowing to read and if you know
what the [__] he's talking about which
is that
he
you know he was this patriotic guy who
supported england and and
was
contributing to that propaganda
this victorian this this this culture of
look look you go over the top it's time
to go you go and and
he lost his son and you wonder what kind
of um
you know how that just the impact that
that had on him and it there is an
impact when you read his poems and you
see before and after you see what
happened
you can see that it definitely had an
impact
but
the
man the idea that
tens and thousands and hundreds of
thousands of of people like you said
like we're like okay cool that's what
we're doing
that's what we're doing we're gonna go
over there and
when they say go over the top we're
gonna go over the top the germans the
french the canadians the americans the i
mean that's what we're doing
it's very very
hard
you know you talk about the value of
life and your question around like what
do they think of these people it's like
yeah
what did they and how did we get to a
point
where
modern civilization
well this is a hundred years ago yeah
it's a hundred years ago
a hundred years ago this was happening
it's like
it's crazy to think about
and uh and you can kind of see i mean
what's there's another good saying uh
it's
uh something along the lines of like old
men like to send young men to fight and
young men like to go fight like that's
kind of a thing right and you can see
how those
sort of animalistic instincts that we
have and tribal instincts that we have
are
and and the heroic instincts that we
have
are captured and capitalized on and
by leica koswitz like when you read
klaus which you're like cool i'm down
with heroic efforts i'm down with
tribal behavior
i'm down with
being brave like all those things just
roll right into this so if you don't
want to be that guy that's sort of like
well
maybe we should think about these
soldiers as human beings
who's doing that apparently no one
apparently no one
so what you have i guess what i'm saying
is you have a
human instinct and a human
animal instinct to be tribal to be
heroic to be sacrificial to make
sacrifices for the tribe i mean what is
a hero you know i've talked about this
before a hero is someone that's not
doing not making a sacrifice for himself
right a hero is someone that's making a
sacrifice for someone else
and that's a common that's just the
definition of a hero in any language
so when you say
hey
we've got kind of a program here
that allows us to be heroic on a massive
scale
this is what you end up with and we kind
of lean towards and we tend towards and
you can see how
you can see how the contrary is that you
have
bh liddell hart who's saying hey not
smart yeah
not smart it's better to maneuver it's
better to leave it's better to retreat
it's better to attack on a different day
and and how is he getting branded he's
getting branded like what the hell are
you talking about were you a coward yeah
is that what's going on you're a coward
he's like hey bro i went wounded three
times and gassed almost to death you
[__] savages and you don't know what
that was like
you talk about
i don't know how many times this has
come up this the the capacity for the
dehumanization
of our enemies and how there's a danger
in there
and there's there's a natural piece of
that but you got to keep it to a to a
certain place
but i think for me just that to
reconcile the dehumanization of your own
men
i i understand the dehumanization of the
enemy i understand that and i also
understand that there is a limit to that
too and if you go too far you can
undermine your own objectives we know
that we know that but the ability to do
that with your own men your your own
people is it's it
i think that's just why
world war one sort of just sits in its
own category of
just so hard to come to grips with
with us doing that
yeah
it does it's it's in its own category as
far as i'm concerned yeah
right
and i guess that's where we end up with
these two
kind of
opposing theories of war
and
who wants to be called the wimp who
wants to be called the weak right
because that's where you could easily go
back to bh without heart and say like he
wants to run away yeah he wants to you
know attack people from the rear there's
a time where attacking someone in the
rear shoot him in the back was like a
horrible thing right it's a sign of
cowardice yeah it's a sign of cowardice
to go around and you know not line up
like the other team
shoot him in the back yeah
you know i i've been
the coolest part about being on the
podcast in this seat is that this is i
hear this live
as you're reading it i don't i don't get
the advanced copy you don't like say
dave we're prepping this
i get to hear this
and i i i'm i'm thinking and i'm trying
to analyzing i'm making connections and
correlations and i've kind of just been
chuckling a little bit of like heart is
just hammering klauswitz
but he he
it's almost like i understand more now
of why he's so brutal on the attack of
him when he made that connection of he's
the reason why
we had generals and i think he used the
word blunders which is about as nice as
you can describe what those leaders did
in world war one is
i actually think i understand why he's
so brutal on him is because of what it
led to and and i don't and i think he's
doing a good job saying i know klaus was
his goal was not to create this
circumstance and he's defending
components of that but his point was
this is the outcome that he created this
his words
and his philosophy is what facilitated
this this window of warfare in our time
that allowed us to dehumanize our own
men
in on a scale that's really
hard to really comprehend and and i
think i'm understanding in real time why
he's saying what he's saying about him
in such a brutal fashion
and i understand it yeah and i kicked
off this whole podcast with the last
podcast by explaining what he'd been
through and i said
this [__] left a mark on him
i mean look it leaves a mark on you when
you lose one guy in combat one
one guy in combat is gonna leave him
you're never gonna forget it you're
never gonna live it down you're never
gonna go a day without thinking about it
can you imagine when your battalion gets
wiped out yeah can you imagine when
you're brigade when you're division when
you take 60 000 casualties in a day
that's what's going on
and and the quote that you're
reaching back for was klaus what's
phrase would henceforce be used by
countless blunderers to excuse and even
justify
their feudal squandering of life in
bullheaded assaults yeah he's talking
about exactly what he lived through
and that [__] left a mark on him without
question yeah
and this is his his opportunity
to tell a generation of leaders
contemplating the impact of that guy's
words
with the reality of without some logical
thinking about what he really is trying
to say
this is the path you will go down and
this is his way of saying you cannot go
down that path yeah you want to go and
read the wave tops of this guy and turn
it into how you're going to fight a war
right you're an idiot
war is an act of violence pushed to its
upmost bounds that's the last quote i
give he says that declaration has served
as a foundation for the extravagant
absurdity of modern total warfare his
principle of force without limit and
without calculation of costs
fits and is fit only for a hate maddened
mob so he's not done yet
it is the negation of statementship and
intelligence strategy which seeks to
serve the ends of policy
if war
be a continuation of policy as switz had
elsewhere declared it it must
necessarily be conducted with a view to
post-war benefit
a state which expands its strength to
the point of exhaustion bankrupts its
own policy and by the way that's all
players in world war one
koswitz himself had qualified the
principle of quote utmost force by the
admission that quote the political
object as the original motive of war
should be the standard for determining
both the aim of the military force and
also the amount of effort to be made
still more significant was a reflective
passage in which he remarked that to
pursue the logical extreme entailed that
quote the means would lose all relation
to the end and in most cases the aim at
an extreme effort would be wrecked by
the opposite weight of forces within
itself
what's the rule what's the return on
investment you're going to get
his classic work on war was the product
of 12 years of intensive thought if it's
author had lived to spend a longer time
in thinking about war he might have
reached a wiser and clearer conclusion
as his thinking progressed he was being
led toward a different view penetrating
deeper unhappily the process was cut
short by his death from cholera in 1830
it was only after his death that his
writings on war were published by his
widow they were found in a number of
sealed packets bearing the significant
and prophetic note so he wrote a note on
his writings and it said
should the work be interrupted by my
death then what is found can only be
called a mass of conceptions not brought
into form
open to endless
misconceptions sorry klaus wits i mean
he covered it he did his best to cover
it yeah
much of the harm might have been avoided
but for that fatal cholera germ for
there are significant indications that
in the gradual evolution of his thought
he had reached a point where he was
about to drop his original concept
of absolute war and revise his whole
theory on more common sense lines when
death intervened in consequence the way
was left open to endless misconceptions
far in excess of his anticipation for
the universal adoption of the theory of
unlimited war has gone
far to wreck civilization the teaching
of klaus wits taken without
understanding largely influenced both
the causation and the character of world
war one thereby it led on all too
logically to world war ii
theory influx next section after world
war one the course and effects of the
first world war provided ample cause to
doubt the validity of clausewitz theory
at least interpreted by his successors
on land innumerable battles were fought
without ever producing the decisive
results expected of them
but the responsible leaders were slow to
adapt their aim to circumstances or
develop new means
to make the aim more possible
and maybe that's why when he was going
through the eight um
items that we were talking about earlier
on the earlier podcast
his number one thing remember you're
saying the number one thing was his
number eight thing
his number one thing was
adjust your adjust your end to your
means and here he's saying the
responsible leaders were slow to adapt
their aim to the circumstances or
develop new means to make the aim more
possible
instead of facing the problem they
pressed theory to a suicidal extreme
draining their own strength beyond the
safety limit in pursuit of an ideal of
complete victory by battle which was
never fulfilled
that one side ultimately collapsed
that one side ultimately collapsed so
the germans ultimately collapsed do more
to emptiness of stomach produced by
economic pressure of sea power than the
loss of blood although blood which was
lost in the abortive germ german
offensive 1918 and the loss of spirit
and consequence of their palpable
failure to gain the victory hasten the
collapse
if this provided
the opposition the opposing nations with
the semblance of victory their efforts
to win
it cost them such a price in moral and
physical exhaustion that they the
seeming victors were left incapable of
consolidating their position
it became evident there was something
wrong with the theory or at least with
its application alike on the planes of
the tactics strategy and policy the
appalling losses
suffered in vain pursuit of the ideal
objective and the post-war exhaustion of
the nominal victors showed that a
thorough re-examination of the whole
problem of the object and aim was needed
besides these negative factors there
were also several several positive
reasons to prompt a fresh inquiry one
was the decisive part that seapower had
played without any decisive battle at
sea and producing the enemies collapsed
by economic pressure that raised the
question whether britain in particular
had not made a basic mistake in
departing from her traditional strategy
and devoting much of her effort at such
terrific cost to herself to the
prolonged attempt to win a decisive
victory on land yeah england freaking
survived forever
just by rolling ruling the sea
britannia rules the waves that's what we
do in england now we're over here
fighting these these people on land
two other reasons arose from the new
factors
the development of air forces offered
the possibility of striking account the
enemy's economic and moral centers
without having to first achieve the
destruction of the enemy's main forces
on the battlefield air power might
attain a direct end by indirect means
hopping over opposition instead of
overthrowing it
good deal dave
i mean that's always been the goal
whether it's whether it's ever going to
prove to be true
you could make a couple arguments but
that's always been the goal we can do
this without actually fighting
on the ground on the ground yeah
at the same time so at the same time we
have air power at the same time the
combined development of the petrol motor
and the caterpillar track opened up a
prospect of developing mechanized land
forces of high mobility this in turn
foreshadowed a newly enlarged
possibility of producing the collapse of
the enemy's main forces without a
serious battle by cutting their supply
lines dislocating their control systems
or producing paralysis by the sheer
nerve shock of deep penetration in the
rear seat also you got vehicles that can
haul ass not get shot up and move a
bunch of troops in a short amount of
time
mechanized land forces of this new kind
might also provide like air power though
in a lesser degree the possibility of
striking direct
at the heart and nerve system of the
opposing country
while air mobility could achieve such
direct strokes by an overhead form of
indirect approach tank mobility might
achieve them by indirect approach on the
ground avoiding the obstacle of the
opposing army
to illustrate the point by a board game
analogy with chess air mobility
introduced the knights move
and tank mobility of queens move into
warfare analogy does not of course
express their respective values for an
air force combined with the vaulting
power of the knights move with the
always flexibility of the queen's move
on the other hand a mechanized force a
mechanized ground force though it lacked
vaulting power could remain an
occupation of the square it gained
a couple other things
these these new
these new technologies
increase the range of military action
against military objectives making it
easier to overthrow an opposing body
such as an army by by paralyzing some of
its vital organs instead of having to
destroy it physically as a whole by hard
fighting if you could you could knock
out some of the key nodes
that's going to be better
the some effect of the advent of this
multiplied mobility both on the ground
and in the air was to increase the power
and importance of strategy relative to
tactics
the higher commanders of the future
would have the prospect of achieving
decisive results much more by movement
than by fighting compared with their
predecessors
unfortunately though skipping ahead a
little bit unfortunately those who were
at the head of the armies after world
war one were slow to recognize the need
of a fresh definition of the military
aim
in light of
changed conditions and war instruments
i mean you should be absolutely
rethinking every you imagine going from
not having tanks and aircraft to having
tanks and aircraft you should be
completely changing
the entire way you're thinking about
warfare
and by the way this is after world war
one right
you know we did a piece we did a podcast
on the boor war and they learned all
these lessons during the boomer war and
they freaking didn't capitalize on any
of them
like world war one shouldn't happen just
based on what they learned in world war
in the boomer war i'm going extreme i
don't want to go this extreme there are
many lessons that that were learned
during the boor war
that they could have taken back and said
we need to do things differently
and they didn't freaking adjust very
many of them at all
well going back to the last podcast and
one of the first comments he made about
the the the natural resistance
the the automatic resistance that will
happen when you propose change and i'm
paraphrasing i don't remember the exact
quote but the idea that when i
suggest a change to the norm there will
be there will be resistance
you know one thing
to call me even a hist an amateur is is
a compliment but i even think about you
know the advent of air power and the
resistance even in the navy to the idea
that air power would somehow supplant
the battleship as the preeminent force
and how
obvious it seems now certainly but at
the time you're thinking hey
do you not can you not see the the
potential advantage if we could somehow
occupy this third dimension of battle
exclusively and how much risk it creates
and the resistance and my guess would be
is that
for the few folks that have the audacity
to vocalize those lessons oh
run out of the navy and by the way
remember the last podcast when i talked
about 17 out of 20 advancements in naval
warfare one of them
was aircraft carriers and air power
totally that's one of the more people
are you kidding me we have a battleship
bro right back off
yeah
it's it's
this book is getting harder and harder
to listen to
it because yeah because the because i
have the the his the hindsight of his of
of what he's saying in the context of
that which he he didn't have the future
context that we all have now but it's
making it just so much more damning to
he you know what he's saying
fast forward a little bit practice in
world war ii
when the next war came the handful of
new
land forces of mechanized kind that
had been created
amply fulfilled the claims that have
been made for them and for their
decisive effect if employed for
long-range strokes
at strategic objectives
unfortunately it's the nazis that are
just going to say yeah a mere six
divisions of this kind were largely
instrumental in producing the collapse
of poland in a few weeks um
a mere 10 such divisions virtually
decided the so-called battle of france
before the infantry mass of the german
army had even come in action and made
the collapse of all western countries an
almost inevitable sequel this conquest
of the west was completed in barely a
month's campaign with amazingly small
costs to the victor indeed the bloodshed
all around was very slight and in the
decisive phase
trifling by a klaus witsian standard
i mean can you imagine you fight those
freaking
three bloody satanic
battles
i mean campaigns in world war one
just incomprehensible and then fast
forward
how many years 20 years 20 years 20
years 22 years whatever and it's over in
less than a month like that's what we're
talking about and there's almost no
bloodshed because it just happened so
fast because we have maneuver on our
side
yeah even and even in between those two
examples not not to marginalize you know
what the germans did to to poland
but it's what happened to the french
that seems
to me more remarkable because
because of of
what they had just been through
and then to see i mean
the image of of hitler
at the eiffel tower i mean
like
that's a that's a
it's hard to put into words what that
means for him to be standing there with
with
with basically no real cost of doing it
relative
uh
crazy crazy while this sweeping victory
was attained by action against
objectives of military nature it was
mainly through action of maneuver
strategic more than tactical so it's a
different he's playing a different game
yeah playing a different game
similar reflections apply
to the even swifter conquest of the
balkans in april of 1941 which once
again demonstrated the paralyzing effect
of the new instruments of strategic
application battle was insignificant in
comparison and destruction palpably an
appropriate term for the way that the
decision was achieved
when it came to the invasion of russia a
somewhat different method was tried many
of the german generals particularly
halder the chief of the general staff
complain of hitler's tendency to aim at
the economic rather than military
objectives but analysis of the
operational orders and of their own
evidence does not bear out the charge
while hitler was inclined to think that
the economic aim would be more effective
it is clear that in the crucial period
of 1941 campaign he conformed to the
general staff's preference for fighting
battles
thankfully thank god yeah
the pursuit of this aim did not prove
decisive although it produced several
great victories in which immense forces
of the enemy were destroyed okay
we went and killed a bunch of russians
whether concentration on economic
objectives would have been more decisive
remains an open question but the
reflection that some of the ableist of
the german generals consider that the
best chance of defeating soviet russia
was lost by aiming to win battles in the
classical way instead of driving through
as fast as possible
to the moral come economic objectives
offered by mascot moscow and leningrad
the leading exponent or gordian the
leading exponent of the new school of
mechanical mobile warfare wish to do
on this key question hitler had cited
with the orthodox school
like we said thank god
[Applause]
in the series of swift german conquest
the air force combined with the
mechanized elements of land forces in
producing the paralysis and moral
disintegration of the opposing forces
and of nations behind its effect was
terrific and must be reckoned fully as
important as that of the panzer forces
the two are inseparable in any valuation
of the elements that created the new
style of lightning war for warfare the
blitzkrieg
so
i'm going to fast forward a little bit
there's a section in here
about
strategic bombing and and what he calls
grand strategic bombing or industrial
bombing and he kind of goes into
into how effective actually how
effective it actually was he says the
the actual effect which this kind of
bombing achieved in contribution to
victory is very difficult to assess
despite much detailed investigation the
estimation of the data is confused
bipartisan estimate assessments both by
those who favored industrial bombing and
those who opposed it on various grounds
apart from the fog thus created a
correct
assessment is handicapped and made
almost impossible by the amount of
imponder bilia
in the data
even more than the evidenced about any
other type of military action
imponderabilia
meaning things that can't be determined
so
he's basically saying that some of the
industrial
bombing may have not have been effective
as we thought it was
fast forward a little bit still clear is
the extremely detrimental effect of
industrial bombing on the post-war
situation again we're going to think
grand strategy we've got to think about
what's happening afterwards beyond the
immense scale of devastation hard to
repair are the less obvious but probably
more lasting social and moral effects
this kind of action inevitably produces
a deepening danger to the relative
shallow foundations of civilized life
think about what you're doing to this
civilian populace and how is that going
to affect the future
that common danger is now immensely
increased by the advent of the atomic
bomb
here we are brought to the fundamental
difference between strategy and grand
strategy whereas strategy is only
concerned with the problem of winning
military victory grand strategy must
take the longer view
for its problem is the winning of the
peace
such an order of thought
is not
a matter of putting the cart before the
horse
but of being clear where the horse and
cart are going
and i'll tell you what with that we're
approaching two hours right now we're
probably really close if not at two
hours and we have a lot more to cover
so
echo is it cool if we wrap this one up
for now sure
all right so
we'll come back to you one more podcast
about this book
and well
about these books
until then
until then and look we're going deep
right now we're we're drinking some
we're drinking some drinks
uh we're getting after it
how do we get these drinks we're
drinking what are we doing you just
cracked another one open sure
where do we go actually real quick i had
a thought that so klaus switz and
liddell hart they're kind of like your
watch karate kid
yes the og original karate kid john
crease
mr miyagi okay yep so
crossfits klaus bits or klaus wits
depends on what kind of an
accent i'm kind of like attempting but
gotcha so he's john crease
strike first strike hard no mercy like
kind of that philosophy wait that's mr
miyagi no that's john crease oh okay you
know kind of the bad guy but yeah he'll
get you fired up he'll get you fired up
the fight
let's face it we all want to say no
mercy in this dojo yeah i kind of like
that fear
does not exist in this dojo jack right
all this stuff so it gets you fired up
you know but mr miyagi for 42nd by the
way oh really using for real life no
okay in the story
i got a book about the 442nd i got to
get a better one i got one of it as a
history book
and it was cool and somebody sent it to
me and i was kind of stoked like yeah
but it was a history book
wasn't a lot of first person i was like
cool we can do history book as long as a
bunch of first person accounts really
wasn't that many in there i got to get i
got to get on the 442nd
i dig it nonetheless mr miyagi his whole
thing was
balanced right takes daniel's son out on
the river or the lake and he has him on
the boat right balance first before he's
like when do i learn how to fight all
this stuff what else did he say why i
learned karate and he was like
so you don't have to fight whatever
the balance man it's what it seemed like
to me i don't know i think there you go
provided some more okay here i am
reading these books and you're just
getting it from a karate kid you could
have figured it all out yeah that's true
nonetheless you are right we are here
drinking discipline go
sometimes you gotta drink discipline go
yeah that's good
unless last time i was saying how now
the path is a little bit easier
thing is i don't know if the path is
actually easier because easy easy is not
the right word
maybe it's comfortable
okay that doesn't sound like the right
word either because like comfort do you
want to be cable you want to be
comfortable
nonetheless it's more pleasurable how
about that
we're drinking discipline go it tastes
good it's good for you it's a win-win
strategically and tactically okay
i think all this stuff is bringing it
all together along those lines
all right same thing with milk you can
have something that tastes really really
good plus provides protein plus it's
healthy boom this is all the jocko fuel
stuff so also we got your joint stuff uh
your immunity stuff joint warfare super
krill oil vitamin d3 and
cold water
that's true
get these things at
jackalfuel.com get the discipline go
energy drinks i'm just gonna call them
energy drinks just for
because that's what we're doing
drinking the energy drinks get those at
wawa and vitamin chop
actually you can get everything from
from vitamin c by the way also yes or at
jockofield.com get the subscription if
you don't want to get uh if you want you
don't want to forget about um you know
just restock check it out if you
subscribe to whatever you want from
jogglefuel shipping's free
and shipping can be expensive let's face
it and we want to not expend
resources that we don't have to
that's true a little indirect attack
get subscription all of a sudden
shipping is free
it's true your resources are spared and
can be utilized for other offensive
operations yeah
that's kind of like a kind of badass way
of saying that right yeah kind of i
agree i agree yeah yeah fully
also speaking of operations origin usa
american made stuff durable goods
clothing
what that means is you want to get some
american-made jeans
made out of american-made denim made out
of american-made cotton
origin usa that's where you can get this
stuff also has athletic wear some uh jiu
jitsu stuff geez rash guards
belts wallets boots
i still have your boots by the way oh
i think i'm gonna need those soon yeah
don't worry they're downstairs in the
car
nonetheless origin usa that's where you
can get this stuff real good stuff it's
a big deal too made in america the way
it is made in america from the beginning
all the way up into the
final product yeah
we have a factory full of awesome
american people up there creating this
stuff sewing it printing it i mean just
every aspect cutting it sewing it it's
just legit and if you follow that if you
if you pull the thread on a pair of
jeans you're going to end up in a cotton
field in in texas
or in georgia like that's where it's
coming from so
know your roots
it's true
speaking of roots also jackal has a
store that's his roots
it's called jocko store that's where you
can get the discipline equals freedom or
good or get after it all you can get the
shirts the hats hoodies
some rash guards on there stuff a bunch
of stuff anyway yeah check that one out
it's at jackostore.com and yeah if you
like something get something we also
have a subscription situation there
called the short locker
if you want a cool
kind of off
shoot
conceptual designs
i don't think you've really figured out
how to describe your designs yet no it's
a work in progress
i see but each time you got to progress
you haven't progressed your description
yeah but just like um what do you call
uh warfare yeah you know you don't
you're not always progressing you see
i'm saying but you want some sometimes
you go forward sometimes you go
backwards you know hopefully the whole
grand uh what do you call freaking grand
strategy yeah
hopefully i end up forward hopefully i
end up achieving the goal
of explaining how cool the shirt locker
is so you already did a better job right
there you just needed a little help a
little help okay good
some criticism some direct feedback
about your weak ass
repetition i'm over here trying and you
know and i think the people are
responding you know people seem to like
it
i gotta admit when we were at the muster
and i saw some people that had you know
shirt locker shirts on totally
representing extra level of connection
yeah yep i agree i felt the exact same
thing anyway yeah sherlock that's at
dropletstore.com so yeah sign up for
that if you're down yeah you can
subscribe to this podcast too we also
have jockle unraveling podcast that i'm
doing with daryl cooper
who knows what's gonna happen we're
getting crazy on that thing got all
kinds of topics we're digging into um we
don't always agree on stuff let's come
come to find out
in dc sometimes it gets a little hectic
in the podcast room uh check out that
the jocko unraveling podcast check out
the grounded podcast check out the
warrior kid podcast you can also check
out we have another
alternative podcast called jocko
underground you can go to
jockowunderground.com
if you want to hear some amplifying
information if you want to hear
some other topics that are adjacent to
yet not fully
embedded with jocko pondcast topics but
look
even though i think about leadership
20 hours a day
there's other things i think about like
psychology like sociology like
questions do answering questions from
people so there's a lot of stuff going
on that also gives us the opportunity to
have an alternative platform
besides the mainstream platforms which
we do not control
we
we don't mind you know being on those
platforms
but
they could make moves that would we
would mind that we would not appreciate
and we know you wouldn't appreciate so
in order to prevent
us from being in a situation that we
have lost total control we have some
contingency plans it's called jocko
underground jockowinderground.com
you can join
we'll get you this little extra podcast
costs eight dollars and 18 cents a month
that way we have it if we need it and if
you can't afford it it's cool
we still got your back you know
email assistants at
jockowunderground.com we've got a
youtube channel where i am the assistant
director for many of the videos
and hence some of the videos have very
high quality some of them that i don't
work on a little bit subpar but cool
echo's working on it he's working on
improving yeah
so there you go
uh psychological warfare it's an album
jack album with chocolate tracks where
you know if you want to skip the workout
you want to cheat on the diet when
you're having those feelings you need
some help boom jacqua's there to help
get you through those moments of
weakness sort of play the tracks boom
and around we go
you can get those anywhere you get mp3s
that's where you can get them amazon
google play all those places and don't
forget about
flipsidecanvas.com if you want to hang
some cool stuff on your wall which you
probably do things that remind you of
the path
go to flipsidecampus.com dakota meyer
imagine having something from dakota
myers hanging in your house it was
freaking just legit
if you think about dakota meyer
you just be like cool i'm gonna i'm
gonna get after it
that's true right that's what i think
yeah fully you know what's funny dakota
dakota and i when we talk we will have
conversations and that we will be
laughing hysterically about stuff
he's not surprised he actually makes me
laugh harder than anyone
currently in my uh regime of contacts
interesting yeah theo vaughn huh
theo can crazy up too that's true yeah
that's a good point but it's a different
kind yeah yeah yeah it's true uh
you know what theo will getting me to
laugh get me laughing on a tactical
level sure
with with
with
playing with dakota man sometimes we're
laughing at us strategic deep level
uh yeah so we got that
flipsidecampus.com dakota meyer we also
got a bunch of books final spin
it's a
book
poem manuscript
transcript
new form new format of literature sure
notice how i said that
new format of literature my wife says
literature because she's british
literature yeah so a new form of
literature which i invented the text
text you got to go oh yeah if you want
to observe the text that's the eyebrow
yeah deal
no no you don't know about that guy yeah
you taught me that did i teach you that
that's what they say did you they say
that in uh when you went to get your
masters or they say if you if you if you
reference the text in this situation
like they don't call it a book
because you're just like a loser if you
just have a book you have to refer to
the text yeah
the text yeah we don't like that
anyways if you want to check out the
text
you can check out final spin you can
pre-order it right now also leadership
strategy and tactics field manual the
code the evaluation the protocols
disciplinary freedom field manual
way the warrior kid one two and three
mike and the dragons about faced by
hackworth extreme ownership of the
dichotomy of leadership
just all the things that we're talking
about when it comes to leadership and
all these different books
also speaking of leadership we have a
leadership consultancy what do we do
dave
we solve problems through leadership
but aren't but what about problems that
aren't really leadership related
all your problems are leadership
problems isn't that crazy
it's true if you want us to come and
help you inside your organization go to
echelonfront.com
we also have an online training program
efonline.com
it's extreme ownership academy we have
we have courses on every chapter we have
live q and a's that we do we have
leadership primers we have questions
today we got we had a forum on there we
got all kinds of stuff on there
to help you with the most important
skill that a human being can have which
is leadership
leadership can prevent things like
freaking the battle of the song
check
muster
2021 orlando done next up phoenix august
17th and 18th
las vegas
october 28th and 29th
these are our leadership
conferences
come and get it
we also have the ftx where you where you
get your gear on
get set up with a high speed laser tag
gun get taught some of the basic tactics
military tactics and then you go with
your team and you
conduct operations
you put these
strategies and tactics and principles
that we talk about all the time you put
them to use
and you see how they work out
and you learn and you get debriefed so
if you want to do that
check out the ftx san diego july 12th
and 13th go to ashlandfront.com
if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families you can check out mark
lee's
mom mama lee she's got a charity
organization and if you want to donate
or you want to get involved go to
america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my exhaustive
explanations or you need more of echo's
disjointed delirium
perhaps you need more of dave's
exhilarated expositions you can find us
on the interwebs on twitter
on the gram and on facebook echoes with
charles dave is that david
r
burke and i am at jocko willink
and to all the military personnel out
there
thank you for taking these tactics
that we are talking about and putting
them to work
around the world to keep us free and the
same to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for keeping us safe here at
home
and to everyone else out there
well
if you know the way broadly
you see it in all things
so i've got an idea
try your best
to open up your eyes
look around
and see the way
in everything that you do
and until next time
this is dave and echo and
out